dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IFA here when we
were children every single one of us
dreamed about having a magic pencil that
would make our adorable little drawings
come true with the power of machine
learning the authors of this paper just
made our dreams come true here's the
workflow we provide a crude drawing of
something and the algorithm fetches a
photograph from a database that depicts
something similar to it it's not
synthesizing new images from scratch
from a written description like one of
the previous works it fetches an already
existing image from a database the
learning happens by showing a deep
convolutional neural network pairs of
photographs and sketches if you're not
familiar with these networks we have
some links for you in the video
description box it is also important to
note that this piece of work does not
showcase a new learning technique it is
using existing techniques on a newly
created database that the authors kindly
provided free of charge to encourage
future research in this area what we
need to teach these networks is the
relation of a photograph and a sketch
for instance in an earlier work by the
name Sai amis networks the photo and the
sketch would be fed to two convolutional
neural networks with the additional
information whether this pair is
considered similar or dissimilar this
idea of Sai amis networks was initially
applied to signature verification more
than 20 years ago
later triplet networks were used to
provide the relation of multiple pairs
like this catch is closer to this photo
than this other one there is one more
technique referred to in the paper that
they used which is a quite delightful
read make sure to have a look we need
lots and lots of these pairs so the
learning algorithm can learn what it
means that a sketch is similar to a
photo and as a result fetch meaningful
images for us so if we train these
networks on this new database this magic
pencil dream of ours can come true
what's even better anyone can try it
online
this is going to be a very rigorous and
scholarly scientific experiment I don't
know what this should be but I hope the
algorithm does well that kind of makes
sense
Thanks algorithm for those fellow
scholars out there who are endowed with
better drawing skills than I am well
basically all of you if you have tried
it and got some amazing or maybe not so
amazing results please post them in the
comment section or as we now have our
very own subreddit make sure to drop by
and post some of your results there so
we can marvel at them or have a good
laugh at possible failure cases I am
looking forward to meeting you fellow
scholars at the subreddit flares are
also available hmm thanks for watching
and for your generous support and I'll
see you next time